they have a weapon like doomsday weapon
we fight to protect the people that we
love let's get to work
[Music]
enough
for me places all those things hey
everybody we got our first genuine
crossover trailer so let's break this
down and we found out what the MacGuffin
is they have a doomsday device so that
might actually set off some warning
bells in your head like wait a minute
that actually sounds familiar but if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get everything
next week is Thanksgiving week so I'll
explain what the schedule is for
everything but nothing is going on break
so no worries there and there is a new
round of that flash ring giveaway I'll
announce a new winner at the end of this
but the really cool thing a lot of you
probably realized is that they're
borrowing from the plot of crisis on two
earths that's an animated movie from a
long time ago but if you're a big fan of
the Justice League cartoons is basically
in that same vein but you have a bunch
of characters from different earths
combining to team up against owl man
from the crime syndicate somewhere in
the multiverse there is a world I call
Earth Brian every earth is a variation
of this one the original and once I
destroy it all reality will follow so
while it's pretty clear that the
reverse-flash or the Blitzen flash of
Earth X is the one that creates the
doomsday device because he's the genius
it sounds like the evil version of
Oliver is the owl man of this equation
like the person who's trying to bring
this evil plan to fruition but that's
really just because Stephen Amell is
sort of their de facto Batman of the DC
TV universe so Stephen Amell a while ago
was teasing that he was really excited
ended be waiting a long time for a very
particular scene and it was him talking
to someone else that was stuck in the
pipeline prison and he was just like
green doubt like so you couldn't quite
tell who it was but you could kind of
see the rivets from the evil all of her
costume on his shoulder here so it's
like oh very clearly he's talking to his
evil doppelganger and tried to find out
why he's trying to either blow their
planet up doomsday device implies that
they're trying to blow the planet up but
the plot of that crisis on two earths
crossover is that there is a device that
can blow up other alternate Earth's an
owl man just goes a little bit nuts and
decides that nothing he does matters so
he can [ __ ] this plan to blow up all of
the multiverse by blowing up our prime
so in the DC TV universe earth one is
sort of the prime universe depending on
which character you're talking to but
I'm not so sure that they're trying to
blow up the entire multiverse though I
don't know if they're borrowing that
much plot from crisis on two earths
because that does seem a little over the
top so we'll see what the evil team-up
is trying to do with that doomsday
device because it doesn't sound like
they're tired of living because they'd
basically be committing suicide if they
were to blow up the multiverse so it
might be one of those scenarios when one
of the evil team members goes rogue but
I'm not expecting that to be evil Oliver
because I think the idea is they want a
more hopeful spin and I don't know
there's all these theories about
Felicity dying the earth X version of
felicity it everybody knows based on the
rules of movies and television that
Nazis Plus Jewish people equal bad
things so that might explain why the
earth X people care so much about what's
going on on earth one because infinite
multiverse infinite versions of Earth
you know why would this earth give a
[ __ ] about what's going on on any one
particular other earth so here's where
we get to the weird part they mixed the
episode order and actually now based on
some of this plot and what's going on
with the evil version of Oliver it makes
a little more sense now so here's the
thing everybody's seen the wedding
pictures with like the entire cast going
to Barry and irises wedding that's
actually the first part of the crossover
so that's the Supergirl episode
everybody goes to the wedding it ends up
being this really nice party then as you
can see over girl and the rest of her
minions crashed the party so like she
bust through the skylight up here in the
window and everybody looks up at her
like holy [ __ ] what's going on now we
know why Joe's crapping his pants so
much and you're just like oh my god this
is gonna be amazing with over girl vs.
Supergirl just going around and around
in the sky in a scenario like that
usually the person who wins is the one
that doesn't hold back and usually
because of but Superman's morals he's
the one that pulls his punches which is
usually why he ends up being defeated is
because he tries to see the good in
people and the villains take advantage
of that so that might be the case with
over girl and Supergirl we're over girl
tries to take advantage of supergirls
goodness but then you see all the storm
troopers rounding people up you see them
doing their buckaroo banzai thing here
where they're all standing shoulder to
shoulder it does
a little ridiculous because there are so
many characters on screen so you're like
okay I hope this ends up looking really
cool but that actually seems like it's
happening from much later in the
crossover so the first part of the
crossover is that Supergirl episode the
wedding the attack the second part is
the arrow episode you see everybody
captured at the mercy of the people on
earth X so it's like they get taken back
to earth X Barry gets the collar on him
so he can't use his powers you meet
pretty much the entire evil team up you
learn about the Blitzen flash and this
is where you get the angry helicopter so
I know everybody's like you know what's
going on here this is probably the
episode where they learn about the
doomsday device you learn the stakes
like oh my god what's going on here
there are evil versions of us and
they're trying to blow up our earth or
blow up the multiverse then you meet the
resistance like the freedom fighters of
Earth X that's where the Ray character
comes in so I know there are a lot of
questions about him they haven't
answered too many we've only got a look
at what his costume looks like but
obviously this is where citizen cold
comes from they have an alternate
version of win from Supergirl so
obviously all four shows are represented
so you have alternate versions of most
of the characters and are there are a
lot of questions about why there's no
alternate berry but I do have a theory
about that I actually think that what
might have happened to Earth X berry is
that the blitzen flash either killed him
or prevented him from becoming the flash
so it may just be that he became the
flash they fought he died and that's the
end of it but this picture of Barry and
iris looks like it's from before the
wedding
Sarah Alex and Supergirl arming up
looking like they're getting ready to
breach back to Earth X to save everybody
the SS compound on earth X looking like
citizen cult is trying to infiltrate it
he might be a double agent then like the
other voice over and the trailer that
you hear everyone you care about then it
gets really crazy and says total victory
that's actually the evil version of
Oliver which is funny because the aro
voice from the normal version of Oliver
on earth one already sounds pretty crazy
so how do you make evil Oliver sound
even more terrifying you make him sound
like he's stepped out of a portal from
hell so it'll be funny to see what his
actual personality is like but like when
you see Barry take down all those
villains and Oliver says leave one for
me the
they cut to evil Oliver's entrance
that's obviously the big matchup that
they're hyping so that's probably why
they're focusing more on that and less
on Barry versus an evil version of
himself even though he will probably
fight the reverse-flash
you don't put a reverse flash in an
episode with the flash without making
them fight each other so I think the
real question here is how is this going
to end because you don't take an entire
planet that's full of Nazis SS evil
superheroes and fix it in four hours
like I think the idea is is they
narrowly avert disaster it might be like
the crisis on two earths ending where
Oliver is able to appeal to evil Oliver
and then once they leave Earth X the
resistance of Earth acts like the REA
citizen cold whoever's left alive at the
end of the crossover just takes things
from there and continues the fight
trying to win people over to their side
but let me know in the comments what do
you guys think about this what do you
think about them doing the crisis on two
earths plotline I know a lot of people
will go run and rewatch that now it's a
little raw but it's still pretty
entertaining story if you're a fan of
those classic cartoons but if you have
any questions or any bonus video
requests just leave them in the comments
below
obviously next week is episode 7 of all
the shows the week after that is all the
crossover episodes they have released
the synopsis for the midseason finales
for all the shows but I'll probably wait
till next week to talk a little bit more
about that because that's separate from
what's happening during the crossover
but I'll say congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Mike the Phil can
please private message me so I can get
your contact details I'll name a new
winner when I post my Justice League
Easter eggs that should be up in the
next couple of hours so hopefully you
guys have had a chance to see the movie
while you wait for everything you can
click here for more crossover footage
and you can click here for my Justice
League post credits video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight